Speaker 1: There is one Republican running
for the nomination right now who's willing
to call out the obvious grift of MAGA cultists
and others that has been perpetrated by Donald
Trump, by Jared Kushner, by all the people
around Donald Trump.
And that one person is obviously Vivek.
No, I'm getting it's Chris Christie.
Okay.
Chris Christie is the one guy that is willing
to say a number of different things that are
obvious, uncontroversial truths to anybody
even remotely connected to reality.
But it's only Chris Christie who's willing
to say it.
Here is Chris Christie on CNN last night saying,
what the hell was Jared Kushner doing in the
Middle East?
What on earth is going on with these grift
and all of these people monetizing their proximity
to power?
Trump himself, not a single other Republican
candidate, is talking about these things.
Listen to this.
Speaker 2: Let's remember something.
He's a billionaire.
A self-professed billionaire.
Why can't he use his own money to pay his
personal legal fees?
Speaker 1: Because he's cheap.
Speaker 2: And not use money coming from the
public.
It's disgraceful and it's a continued grift.
And look, the Trump family has been involved
in grifting for quite some time.
Yep.
He was doing this in terms of the people who
got paid out of this PAC before, whether it
was Kimberly GUILFOYLE or other.
Speaker 1: That the Trump charity.
I mean, there's no there's no end to the grift.
Speaker 2: Members of the family.
Jared Kushner, six months after he leaves
the White House, gets $2 billion from the
Saudi sovereign wealth fund.
Yet when.
Speaker 1: We haven't hear haven't heard Rhonda
sanctimonious talking about.
Speaker 2: That, Trump had put him in a position
to be in the Middle East.
What was Jared Kushner doing in the Middle
East?
Speaker 1: Better late than never, folks.
Speaker 2: We had Rex Tillerson and Mike Pompeo
as secretaries of state.
We need Jared Kushner.
He was put there to make those relationships
and then he cashed in on those relationships
when he left the office.
So what Donald Trump's doing now is just a
continuation of what he's permitted his family
to do.
Speaker 1: And to be clear, what Chris Christie's
talking about is that Trump is now fundraising
for a legal defense fund for all of these
different cases, for all these different indictments
that he's facing.
And Chris Christie is saying, why?
Why do you need to fundraise for that?
He's so rich.
Speaker 2: Over the entire course of his time
as president.
Speaker 3: Why do you think he's not using
his own money to pay for his legal team?
Speaker 2: Because he's the cheapest person
I've ever met in my life.
That's why.
And what he's very good at, Caitlin, is spending
other people's money.
Right.
And if you look at his history in New Jersey.
Speaker 3: You think he's misleading his voters,
his supporters by.
Speaker 2: I think those supporters, you know,
write a check to Trump for president.
They think they're paying for campaign expenses,
not for personal legal expenses.
Now.
Speaker 1: In Trump's defense, I don't even
know that it's a Trump defense.
There are cultists so deep in the cult that
they are glad to pay for Trump's legal defense
because they believe that the indictments
are political, that it's actually Joe Biden
doing it and all these different things.
So like I think Chris Christie is right that
there are some Trump donors who think the
money is being used for the campaign.
There are some who know it's being used for
the legal defense and are fine with that.
And there are those who are in this position
where they believe that the legal defense
is kind of part of the campaign because the
indictments are part of the campaign against
Trump, which is a crazy there's no evidence
of that whatsoever.
Chris Christie was a defender of Trump for
a long time.
And for that, he you know, I think he deserves
to be criticized.
At least he is saying this stuff now.
And no other Republican running in that primary
is willing to do it.
Here is Chris Christie.
Also, most of them won't talk about January
6th in these terms either, but even Mike Pence
won't talk about January 6th in these terms.
And they wanted to kill Pence.
But Chris Christie will talk about it.
Good for him.
Speaker 2: Four killed.
Speaker 3: Exactly as.
Speaker 2: Strong as two people were killed.
Caitlin, as you know, that day on Capitol
Hill defending the Capitol, we had members
of Congress who were running for their lives.
We have people trying to hunt down the vice
president, the United States.
CHENEY Hang Mike Pence.
Right.
And Donald Trump the entire time sat outside
the Oval Office in that little dining room,
his eating a well-done cheeseburger and watching
TV and doing nothing to stop what was going
on until it got to the point where even he
could no longer stand it.
And he finally or for something in the afternoon,
put out a video asking people to leave the
Capitol.
And Ron DeSantis doesn't have any opinion
on that.
Look, I know, by the way, I'm pretty sure
I know who that high school student was.
He goes to every town hall meeting in New
Hampshire.
He's been to three of mine and he asks really
tough questions.
And I said to him, the last time we had a
town hall meeting, he was out of mind.
See if any of the candidates will answer your
questions directly and grade them on it.
Speaker 1: They won't.
They won't.
So listen, again, we don't have to now rehabilitate
Chris Christie into some hero.
It is a very useful thing to see a Republican
drop some truth bombs on maggots or MAGA donations
or MAGA battalions.
I think that that is a good thing.
He, Chris Christie was complicit in the Trump
nonsense for years.
He stood behind Trump and endorsed him in
the entire thing.
And for that he deserves our criticism.
And now he is the only guy running in this
primary who is willing to say some of these
things.
And so we can praise that.
Here's one more one more clip about the January
six stuff.
Speaker 3: If he asked you that question,
how would you answer it?
Speaker 2: I would say it was one of the most
disgraceful days in American history and that
the president was principally responsible
for it.
Speaker 1: Right.
One, not a single other Republican is willing
to say that through.
Speaker 2: The conduct and his words from
election night forward, inciting people and
insisting that the election was stolen when
it wasn't.
Through his speech that day when he attacked
directly his own vice president and incited
those people to be angry at Mike Pence, who
was just performing his constitutional duty.
And he had no choice.
And every lawyer, good lawyer, had told people
that that he couldn't do anything different
than that.
And then while the event was going on, while
the riot was going on, on Capitol Hill, we
know that Donald Trump was watching it and
was being urged by even members of his own
family to get out there and say something.
And he refused because he was enjoying watching
people yell, scream and destroy things in
his name.
Speaker 1: This is all undeniably true, and
Trump will never admit it and insists that
it's fake news.
Chris Christie holding steady at 2.5% in the
Republican primary.
The only guy willing to tell these what should
be uncontroversial truths.
And if I had to choose from the current Republican
slate, who is the next president?
Without a doubt it would be Chris Christie.
One of our sponsors today is replace your
mortgage.
Mortgages are a really interesting thing in
the United States.
The poor often can't afford them and the rich
often don't use them.
Instead, the wealthy use special financial
tools to pay off their debts, often in a fraction
of the time that it takes for a middle class
American to realize that same payoff Replace
your mortgage teaches you how you can pay
off your home in 5 to 7 years without needing
to make more money than you're currently making
right now.
And in addition, they can teach you how to
better utilize your existing assets and equity
to begin or continue growing wealth and passive
income through additional strategies.
And they actually have an upcoming workshop
that will show you how you can take advantage
of these strategies, how it all works.
Create your own economy in a sense, you can
go to replace your university dot com slash
Pacman.
To watch the interview I did with their founder,
Michael Lush, to learn how you can get exclusive
access to what can be a life changing virtual
event.
The link is in the description.